[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN ROBERTS: It
is great to be here.
I know a couple
of familiar faces
from the time I came and gave a
very different talk, about six
months ago.
So thank you very much
for having me back.
So today we're
going to talk a bit
about the process I went
through when I ended up
landing the commission to do
the maps for "Game of Thrones,"
for "The Lands of
Ice and Fire" book.
Just to give you a bit
of a context, the maps
you see here-- I'll talk
a bit more about the ones
that I brought a
little later today--
but that's the actual
size of the maps that
ended up in the final book.
So the book itself has 12 maps.
They're folded, rather
than rolled like this,
but it is just a book of maps.
So it is just 12 maps
of the world of Westeros
and the lands that go all
the way to the far east, way
beyond anything we've seen in
the books or in the TV show.
Yeah, there we go.
So this is how it all started.
This is January 2012.
I got an email
from Random House,
which basically said, like, hi.
Do you fancy mapping all
of Westeros and all lands
to the east?
And this was something
of a surprise
because my secret,
particularly at this point,
was that I wasn't a
full-time professional artist
or cartographer.
I was actually a
theoretical physicist.
So it's a little
surprising to get an email
like this landing in your inbox.
Now I did draw maps
for third-party books,
for some games, for those kind
of bits and pieces, for fun.
But I was getting paid
on a regular basis
to do this kind of work.
But when you look for
fantasy map artists,
there aren't many of
them in the world.
And a lot of them
are a bit older,
like 10, 12, 15 years older.
And I just don't think they
understand search or SEO
at all.
So my little blog just quietly
floated up the rankings
until, when somebody
Googles fantasy artist,
my blog turned up right on
the front page for maps.
And so clearly, Random
House had a bit of hunt
around, found this,
and said, oh, OK.
This guy sounds good.
Let's see what we can do.
Now I'd read the books already.
I'd read them back in when I was
in college, back around 2001.
And the one thing I
thought at that point
was that, wow, these
things could really
do with some-- like,
these are big worlds,
and big worlds need big maps.
So this was the maps
that existed at the time.
These are the ones
that are actually
in the front of the paperbacks.
They're kind of perfect
for a paperback.
They're black and
white line art.
There's a huge
amount of information
crammed in here, which
is why the style has
to be super simple,
so that you can really
pull all that detail out.
But it's a far cry
from the evocative maps
that you render up
in your mind when
you're reading these books.
This is a very rich world that
George R. R. Martin built,
as HBO has shown
time and time again
with the stuff that
they put on top of this.
And so when I originally read
the books, I remember thinking,
yeah, these could do
with some good maps.
At that point, I had never
drawn a professional map
when I read the books.
So it's interesting that over
the course of the next 10
years, me and the
books diverged wildly.
I went off and
started drawing maps.
And then they came crashing
back together again
when I got this email
from Random House.
I actually hadn't read them
for a long time at that point.
I had this vague memory
of what the books were,
and I definitely hadn't
read the most recent one.
So the answer was,
yes, definitely,
and then went out shopping.
Also, because I was a
theoretical physicist
at the time, it was
like, yes, definitely.
I have no idea how this
is going to happen.
And I more or less had
to run the entire thing
past who my wife,
who was like, yeah,
I'll see you in the summer.
Which is actually more or
less how that happened.
So the brief was 12 poster maps.
Each map is 22 by 36, so
2 foot by 3 foot maps,
covering all of the
known lands that
existed plus more lands that had
yet to ever be seen by anyone.
And there would be three
months to do it, so a week
a map, each one this size.
Which was definitely
the, yeah, this
is going to be interesting.
So 72 square feet of Westeros.
And this is, to
put it in context,
a significant portion of
my apartment at the time
would be covered by Westeros,
Essos, and the two cities.
Also, the actual process
of drawing the maps all
happened on this laptop.
So everything that
you see here was all
drawn on a screen this size with
a Wacom tablet in Photoshop.
So when I got these, which are
the intermediate edit stage,
was the first time
I'd ever seen any
of these full size, which
was a huge sigh of relief.
It was like, oh, it worked.
That's kind of good to know.
During the process of this,
I upgraded my hard drive once
and my RAM three times.
It was like 16 gig of RAM,
an external SSD, and-- yeah,
a composite SSD hard drive
and this one [INAUDIBLE]
before Photoshop
would finally take it
all the way to the last stage.
So the anatomy of a map,
because this is basically
how my process worked before
this commission started.
So you talk to the author.
You get the original sketches.
You kind of chat back and forth.
You get an idea of what
things are important,
what things are less important.
You try and find things that
maybe the author thought
was a great idea but don't
work geographically-- deserts
beside forests,
rivers that flow right
across continents from
one ocean to the other.
All those kind of
things just come up.
And so you then pin
down the stuff that's
still up in the
air, and then you
get on, use that information,
use their sketches
to create the line art, just
black and white line art.
Get that signed off.
Then do a full color render.
At the line art stage,
you should always
have all the
information in the map.
It should be a perfectly
functional, accurate, usable
map at the line art stage.
Then everything after that
point is just extra credit.
It's all style
from that point on.
And really, the big part of
doing the full-color render
is making sure that
you're not losing access
to all the information that
you got in at the first stage.
And then at the end,
final tweaks, handover.
Now this was obviously going to
be a slightly different process
because there were many more
people in this process than me
and the author, unsurprisingly.
And also, having any discussion
which says, so, that thing
you came up with in the books,
that doesn't really work,
so can we change it-- was not
going to happen in this case.
In the end, I think there were
two or three editors involved
between me and
George R. R. Martin.
So there was something of
a game of Chinese Whispers
between the two to get all
the stuff working, which,
given any email
that came through me
would have got in the way of
him writing "Winds of Winter,"
I think everybody in this
room and also out there
on the internet would probably
have murdered me in my sleep
if anything had
pushed that back.
So first thing, the sketches.
What do these look like?
I do have them.
I have the full set
of original sketches
from George R. R. Martin that
were the basis for all of this.
I am under an ND, so I can't
show you the full thing.
I'm really sorry.
On the other hand,
if somebody wants
to come up and have a
chat quickly afterwards,
where we're not being videoed,
and this isn't being projected
straight onto YouTube, we
might be able to do something.
So yes, I have the full set
of sketches just sitting
on my hard drive here.
George R. R. Martin just
did a recent interview
in "Rolling Stone."
And this was a particularly
interesting line to me.
It was like, oh, I don't
build the world first.
I just kind of write the
book, put the story in,
and then put the world together.
Drawing a map took me, I
don't know, half an hour.
I've seen his sketches.
He's got far more
detail in those
than you could ever
put in in half an hour.
If I'd had a whiff that this was
the kind of thing he was saying
about the maps
before I started, I
would have budgeted
a lot more time
for dealing with his
line art sketches.
It would not have been needed.
The sketches are
pinpoint accurate.
Everything that you see
here was on those sketches,
more or less, all
in the right place,
all, when they combine
together, line up beautifully.
This was a dream basis to
actually start working from.
I've seen some which,
from other authors who
shall remain nameless, that
have been done in crayon.
That's actually happened.
His were beautifully
rendered in pencil
with particular
things highlighted
in different
colors, like forests
drawn in in green pen,
major locations all
noted with a symbol that
denoted what kind of location
they were-- like big
keeps, small towns,
ruins, all that kind of stuff.
I mean, spot on accurate.
It was great.
And huge.
I mean, they're massive.
They were all drawn out, on
his part, on loose leaf paper
and then just compiled together.
So there were just all
these individual sheets
of letter-sized
paper, which have all
been drawn on individually,
and then he's clearly just
had pieces of tape that
he's stuck onto them.
He's carried on
his pencil drawing.
And he's drawn this one massive
composite, stitched together
world map on sheets
of paper, which
all works and is all accurate.
And then what I got was the scan
of all of those sheets of paper
that I then reconstituted
back in in Photoshop.
And when I was looking
at this, I thought, well,
starting with the
kind of maps that we
have on the front
sheets of these books,
they're pretty small.
How are they going to blow up
to be these things, particularly
when there's three of these maps
that when you put them together
are actually three separate
pieces of the world?
You've got the west, central
Essos, and the far east.
And when you compile
those all together,
that's a six foot wide map,
which is three foot tall.
I mean, this is a big map.
But his pencil
sketches are four foot
wide when you compile
them in photo.
I was like, oh, OK.
We've actually got all
the detail we need.
We've got the right
size to begin with.
We're not going to be
filling in a lot of blanks.
So it was an enormous relief.
It came with incredibly
detailed notes.
So there were like
paragraphs and paragraphs
about each of these areas.
And so this-- I'm going
ahead a little bit.
This was the very last note on
the notes that came through.
Clearly he'd ended up
putting a lot more work
into these maps in this
stage than he'd expected to.
So he says, "I need to
stop mapping for a while.
If I had to come up
with one more name,
I think my head would explode.
Then the Dothraki
would name my neck,
'the place of the bloody
stump.'" So that's how my notes
got signed off when
they came to me.
It was like, OK then.
I think we're good.
So that's the [INAUDIBLE]
from the author.
We had a system set up, and
we had a couple of editors.
We kind of knew
where we were going.
We had a deadline,
which, by this point,
was starting to get
relatively close.
So there's a very,
very light background
there that you can
see, which was the base
that I used to begin with.
And then as we'd go
forward, you start
adding onto the top
of that with lines.
So this was taking the
rough pencil outlines
and going into a coastline.
So that's where the
coastline comes from.
Then you add in the mountains,
put in the mountain ranges.
And then you'll
see other features
just kind of start to appear.
This is the process
that it goes through.
The mountains are
always the first thing
you want to do
because that gives you
all of the major structural
geographic features.
You don't want to stick a
river in and then find out
your mountains are drawn
in the wrong place.
So that's where
the rivers come in.
You've got the hills in there.
Then things like forests,
roads, they all come in later.
And this was really
just an exercise
in going into the
existing maps, going
through all of those
features one by one,
and then just slowly
and categorically going
through each of the
individual steps
to make sure that all that
detail was uniform in style
and consistency across
the whole set of maps.
So those lines you
see right there
are exactly the lines you
see on the pieces of map
in front of you.
The line art that underlies
this is exactly what
ends up in the maps.
And really, at the
end of the day,
this was just an awful
lot of line drawing.
This took a bunch of time.
So whilst all this was going on,
I got through a ton of Netflix.
There are some good TV
series out there if you just
need to listen to them.
"West Wing" is great.
I got through all of both
seasons of "Dollhouse" whilst
doing this.
And then I also decided,
rather than buying "Dance
with Dragons" and
reading it in text form,
I just had it as an audio book.
So I had "Dance with
Dragons" in my ear
as I was drawing the maps.
It was kind of full
sensory "Game of Thrones"
immersion, which I'm
not sure is healthy.
It was also, because
we're talking like March,
April time, "Game of Thrones"
just came out on the TV
at the same time.
It's like, oh, I should
be watching that as well.
So there was actually
an evening where
I was sitting in a corner
at my friend's apartment
because they had HBO.
I was drawing the maps, and I
was watching "Game of Thrones"
in the background so I could
keep an eye on if there were
any major geographic
things that came up,
and also because
it's a great show.
There was a slight hiccup.
So as I mentioned, I wasn't at
this point a full-time artist.
I actually had a day
job I had to be in.
And inconveniently,
there was a trip
to Argentina planned because
there's a big ultra-high energy
cosmic ray telescope down
there, and there was a big group
meeting.
So I spent a couple of weeks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ROBERTS:
Yep, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I went to the
OJ meeting to do
a whole bunch of ultra-high
energy cosmic ray astrophysics
in the middle of doing
this commission, which
means that a decent
chunk of these mountains
were all drawn in the back
of the conference hall
in Malargue whilst
listening to OJ talks.
Conveniently, there
are an awful lot
of mountains in the high
Pampas in Argentina.
Conveniently, there
are also an awful lot
of mountains in
"Game of Thrones."
So I spent a huge amount
of time actually using
the Argentinian Andes as
inspiration for the "Game
of Thrones" mountains.
An odd version of synchronicity.
OK.
That's fine for all of the
big, sweeping geographic maps
you see here.
There are a couple in
here which are city maps.
It wasn't just going
to be drawing out
all the different
locations for the world,
but we're also digging
in and showing off
another map of King's Landing.
King's Landing had
been mapped before.
But the first ever map
of the city of Braavos.
Just before I go any
further, how many people
here haven't read the books?
OK.
I think I've flagged up
most of the spoilers.
I think we'll be all right.
For the people who haven't
read the books, that
map that's right over there,
you should not look at.
That has life lines
of characters.
And when a line
stops, it either means
you got to the end of
their story in the book,
or you got to the
end of their story.
You get to decide.
So that's fair warning.
Yeah, so there's a
couple of cities.
These are two big
cities in the books.
King's Landing,
obviously, everybody
knows about King's
Landing and the major part
it plays in the story.
And there's also
Braavos, which we've
heard about in the TV series.
We know the First
Sword of Braavos.
We know the Iron
Bank of Braavos.
We've started to hear
a bit more about it.
It hasn't actually
been shown yet.
I'm really intrigued
to see what it
looks like when we get
there, having spent
an awful lot of time mapping it.
But they said, these
are the two city maps.
We want to throw these in here.
They're going to
be top-down maps.
By top-down, I mean
like a satellite view.
So you're just drawing
in roads and blocks.
And that's a bunch of work.
You've got a lot
of detail on there.
But it's fine.
So that was kind of a chunk
of time to be blocked aside.
There we go.
So for the people who
haven't read the books,
there is a map of
Braavos coming up here.
So this is the first ever
top-down view of Braavos.
This is the overview
of the city.
It's kind of a Venetian city.
It's got a lot of canals, a
lot of boats, a lot of rivers.
And this was an exercise that
was interesting because George
had a sketch of it
that he'd loosely done,
but he hadn't gone
into a lot of detail.
And there's a lot of
locations that are just
mentioned in the
books that didn't
appear on the sketch map.
So this was a point
of it where I actually
spent a bunch of time
going through the text
and trying to figure out where
everything should end up.
King's Landing is on
the top right there,
which is amazingly
rectangular as a city.
It's like the New York-- it's
the Manhattan of Westeros
cities.
It's like, right.
It's a rectangle.
Let's just go for a rectangle.
And then down at
the bottom, you can
see the actual outline
of the Red Keep.
The Red Keep didn't have
an outline or a floor plans
that I'd ever seen, so
that was just my take
on what the Red Keep's
floor plan would be.
We'll return to that particular
point in a little moment.
But with Braavos,
it was much more
a matter of taking the
rough outline, digging,
and throwing a lot more
detail, and putting the canals
and putting the bridges,
putting all the major locations
in there.
And this meant
going to the books.
Obviously, leafing
through, page by page,
all of the actual
books and trying
to find the sections
of Braavos in there
would have taken forever.
Thankfully, there are Kindle
versions of these books.
They are searchable.
You can highlight them
and bookmark them.
So I have a fully
bookmarked set of the books
to date, which have
pretty much everything
that has a major geographic
piece of information in it
just highlighted, so I can
go back and flick through it.
Also, because in the books,
they have character names
at the beginning
of it, and I knew
exactly who went to
the different places,
it made it very easy to pull out
the Braavos sections relatively
quickly.
But that wasn't quite
as much far as it went.
It turned out,
actually, Braavos is
going to become
and remain and stay
quite crucial to the
future of the books.
So that meant that
I got chapters
of "Winds of Winter,"
which was very nice.
Now just to give you
an idea, this is 2012.
There were finished chapters
of "Winds of Winter" in 2012.
I'm not going to say any more.
So actual parts
of the Braavos map
are directly involved
with "Winds of Winter."
And so if you have read the
books, and you're thinking,
that's fine, there's no spoilers
on earth in this [INAUDIBLE]
area, you're probably
wrong because somewhere,
I think, there's a Braavos
map kicking around.
And that's definitely
got spoilers in it.
And so this really meant
going through the books,
finding out, right down
to following characters,
seeing exactly what their path
was, whether they turned right,
whether they turned
left, how far they'd go,
and taking all of those
different locations, which
had unspecified places, and just
figuring out where in the city
they could be without things
just being fundamentally
logically inconsistent.
So that took a while.
And then obviously,
I was basically
suggesting, sending these
notes back, saying, well,
this is what I think
the city looks like.
And that obviously caused fairly
lengthy chains of emails going,
well, we're not sure
this should go there,
and then arguing back and forth.
But this was actually a
great and really interesting
process and nailed down a
lot of places very quickly.
And I learned an awful lot
about Braavos in the process
because there was all
the justification.
Oh, it can't be there.
Even though it makes
sense geographically,
it really should be here
because this is why it's there.
I also found that most
of the places that
have a lot of distinction
are the brothels or bars.
It's important to
know where they are.
And so then you get the
line art signed off.
So you say, OK, that's fine.
Here's all the line art.
We've had a lot of discussions.
It's all good.
Let's go into color.
But wait.
We have a twist.
They have suddenly
said, oh, actually.
We kind of like top-down
views of cities.
But you know what
we like a lot more?
We like three-quarter
views of cities.
So we like views coming
in from the side.
We want to see as if you were
aerial view, looking down
at the stuff.
It's like, oh,
that's interesting.
Because a week a
map for-- OK, right.
So the response, obviously,
was like, I'm not
suggesting George R.
R. Martin is actually
a swap for God of Death.
Yeah, so we said, well, OK.
Clearly we're going to do that.
Clearly those maps
would be amazing
if we can have a three-quarter
view of all these cities.
You can actually
start to really see
what these locations look like.
It's going to take
a little longer.
And I didn't have a lot
of experience drawing.
I'd done a bunch of city
maps before, but never
anything on this
sheer scale before.
So just trying to
figure out, when
you get to a map of this
size, when you do a city
map in that kind of style, what
you end up getting away with,
what you can actually do and
what you need to throw in there
is tricky.
And it was kind of an unknown.
So I gave myself a
decent amount of leeway,
but I think with city maps like
that, you can put as much time
as you ever wanted into it,
and you're still never going
to be able to get every
single detail right.
And so then we
started saying, right,
which way do want
to see these cities?
How do you want to look at it?
So we threw back and forth
a bunch of layout sketches.
This is the layout sketch
that actually ended up
going into the Braavos map.
So now we start seeing the whole
thing's got a big perspective
skew on it.
We can now start seeing
mountains and the surrounding
lagoon.
We start getting some
structural details.
You can see at the top right,
that's the Sealord's Palace,
where you start
seeing some spires.
Just really roughly laying
in which of the regions
you're going to start
getting proper detail out of.
And then a little over--
plan view on the bottom left.
And then for King's
Landing, this
was what it ended
up looking like.
So this is, you can
see all the streets,
but you can see all
the little houses.
Braavos, each of the
blocks is a block.
It's an actual single building.
King's Landing, it's all
tiny little buildings.
Thousands upon
thousands upon thousands
of tiny little buildings.
So that was the
first ever outlined
sketch for King's
Landing, to give
a rough idea of how
this would look.
So you see the big
surrounding wall.
Now, King's Landing's a
big, highly populated city.
If you actually broke
those down and tried
to calculate the population
per individual building there,
you don't get enough
houses for the population.
So it still should be
representative rather
than realist.
And obviously, you can see the
height of the towers there.
This is a multi-- well, this
is a hell of a lot of people.
With a city this
size, you would never
be able to see the wall
on that scale around it.
So it was trying to go for some
kind of forced realism, where
you have much larger
representations
of the key buildings.
So a really big Red Keep
because that's obviously
very important.
You can see the Sept of Baelor.
You can see the
dragons, the dragon pit.
And you can see the big
gates, and you get some idea.
You can see where Flea
Bottom is because it's
much denser, richer,
much more mashed up.
But also, when you look at it
from a three-quarters view,
it's kind of hard to
get the sense of height.
And King's Landing has three
big hills in it, like big hills.
So you've got the one with the
dragon pit on the top right.
You've got the Sept of
Baelor on the bottom left.
And you've got the hill that
the Red Keep itself sits on.
Yeah, we'll talk a bit more
about the hills a little later.
But this was basically,
when it got to this point,
everyone's happy.
This is what we're
going to do with.
These are the two
layouts for the cities.
At which point,
we put that aside,
and I just started
drawing hundreds
upon hundreds upon
thousands upon thousands
of little houses.
I think about a
month after this,
my wrists started
moving properly again.
It was a long process.
A note on all the names.
These maps are
great illustrations.
I really enjoyed doing all
the illustration work on them.
They are massively detailed
text documents as well.
There's a huge density
of names in this place.
When you actually
get to Westeros--
I think somebody's got
the actual Westeros
map running around.
If there's a bigger one
somewhere down there.
The sheer number of names
on there is astonishing.
And these names aren't ones
that you can just spell check.
So if I'd had to do
all of that as well,
this would never
have got finished.
Random House and Del Rey
did an amazing thing.
They went to the guys who
run Westeros.org, which
is the biggest website Wikipedia
database for "Game of Thrones"
knowledge.
And they got the two people
who run that, Elio and Linda,
to come on as fact checkers.
And they ended up running
through all of these things.
They cross-checked every
single one of these maps
to make sure that all
of the text was right,
which was an astonishingly
long task to go into.
And for the journeys map,
which is just over there,
they actually put together
the path of every character
through every book to the
end of the published books
and basically printed out that
map I showed you earlier on,
which was the one in the
front of the books, with--
and there were, well, one
for every single character.
It was just this massive
FedEx tube of these maps,
where they'd just drawn every
single path on with notes
on what happened at each place.
Yeah, they did an epic
amount of work on this.
OK.
So now we've got the
line art signed off.
All is well with the world.
We're moving on quite nicely.
The process I
actually go through
for rendering a set of maps.
You pick a good
background texture.
You always start with a
good, interesting, solid base
with a bunch of texture on it.
Lay in the core colors.
Add in the basic
light and shade,
which starts to give you a
three-dimensional feel to it.
Deepen and lighter,
deepen shadows and add
some bright highlights.
And then stick your text
or labeling on top of that
and work on the whole image
at once to retain consistency.
And that's an interesting
one because when
you have things these size and
you have a screen this size,
you don't want to
work on a piece,
go off and do something
different over there.
You're basically like, I'm
doing all my mountains.
I have to do all the
mountains now and do that
not just on one map,
but across all the maps
because a lot of these
cover the same area.
So you see the same places
in different regions of maps.
So retaining consistency
both in style, but also
exact representation across all
of these, was really important.
To the extent that when you take
the really big maps, the ones
of the west, central
Essos, and the far east,
and you line them up, it
should actually line up spot
on in most places-- at least for
the far east and central Essos,
you can line those up directly,
and they'll just match up.
So this is a screen shot
from the center of Essos.
This is the Bone
Mountains, which
divides places like
Qarth and the Red Waste
from all the stuff that lies
to the further [INAUDIBLE]
like Asshai and the Shadow.
So these are like big, epic
mountains sitting on top.
So starting off
by taking the sea.
Throwing in the details
there, adding some color,
playing around with
different tones
and how that's going to feel.
And then starting to
pull in the color.
You can see that.
And then throwing the shadow,
adding in the highlights,
and then finally throwing
in the roads and the labels
and the icons on top.
And so that's what
really takes it
from being just a straight-up
piece of line art,
where you can see all of
these individual things,
but you don't really
have feeling for it,
to actually starting
to build this
into a proper illustration.
And you hope that at
the end of the day,
you still see all
the detail you threw
in there at the beginning.
And so this was the first
version of the known world.
That is the original
color scheme
that went in for the maps.
Now, as you can see,
there's actually--
so this is the version
of it which exists,
which was version two.
So you kind of see
the-- I'll throw this
up here so you can see
there-- so you can actually
see the difference in the color
scheme that went in there.
So that was the first pass.
They were like, oh,
that's kind of nice.
But we have some changes.
So it went back.
And the feeling was, good.
Nice.
We have all the ideas
in the right place.
We kind of like the colors.
But it's a bit too cold.
Let's make it more inviting.
Which was a comment I
was surprised at, given
that the one phrase
you hear over and over
and over again is
"Winter is coming."
Well, I kind of
thought cold and grim
was where we were
going with this.
But OK, we can warm this up.
We can warm this up a lot.
Let's make Westeros
more inviting.
Go for it.
And so this is the color scheme
that went into the newer world.
So this the map that you see
kicking around on the table.
And this was basically
a one-off recolor
of the whole lot, which
wasn't actually going
back and recoloring mountains.
So mountains, all the light
and shade is still the same,
but you need to put in a
bunch of adjustment layers
which change the
warmth and the hue,
and make sure that all
works without screwing up--
like if you warm up your
plains, and you don't do it
to your forests
correctly, then it's all
going to look very weird.
So went back, recolored
a bunch of stuff.
That's these maps
that you see here.
And then there was a comment in
this one that pretty much came
straight back from Mr. Martin,
which is like, too beige.
Far too warm.
This is an intense world.
We should have lots
of contrast, and it
should feel-- you
should really feel
the cold in some
of those places.
Like, OK, right.
We'll go back again.
And so this is now
the color scheme
that ended up going
with at the end there.
So you can see this
process back and forth,
changing different
things, working
on the particular
pieces that need
to be emphasized
more than others.
So one thing you'll
notice here, there's
much more detail in the sea.
There was a real feeling
that the Summer Sea-- so this
is where Daenerys had
been sailing right
before she got to
the Slaver's Bay
and went in to start
sacking slaver cities,
she sails through
the Summer Sea.
And it was made quite clear that
this is a Mediterranean feel.
This is like bright azure
seas and should really
feel like summer.
And then we go farther
north, we should
be starting to throw
in like ice floes
as it gets dark
and cold up there.
And then towards
the bottom left,
you see it gets into this
really dark, almost black blue
because that's really
a feeling of this,
like you're reaching
the end of the world.
There's nothing out there.
There's nowhere to go from here.
This was also, all
these maps were
supposed to be drawn
from the point of view
of one of the maesters
of the Citadel.
So it's a very Westeros-centered
view of the world.
The detail starts to
fall out as you go east.
But also, a lot of the
things-- the different lands
are quite literally represented.
So the Red Waste
went from being kind
of reddish but mostly desert
to being properly red.
And the Shadow went from
being darkish to being
really close to that.
We have like a dark purple
forest out in the bottom right,
in Ulthos.
So this isn't supposed
to be literal.
It's supposed to be an
impression of the world.
So Valyria went
from, in these maps,
I think it's just kind
of a peninsula which
is kind of green.
And this is old Valyria.
This is where the dragon empires
were and the Fall of Valyria
happened.
And so it was-- we
had the discussion.
It's like, no, actually,
this place is still burning.
The Smoking Sea is smoking.
There are fires going on here.
There are ruins.
And so that was basically,
there were these great emails
that went back and forth.
It was like, is
this burning enough?
And do you want it
to be burning more?
It's like, yeah, add lava.
Right, OK, we can
add lava to this.
So when you look at the
actual maps the final maps--
we don't have them here
today, unfortunately.
But if you get a hold of
the actual books themselves,
and you go through,
and you say, oh,
why is this
represented like this?
I can tell you, you
can see how kind
of geographic the
intermediate ones that
went to being much more
heightened, much more
fantastical in the
end version like this.
That's all for a reason.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So were you working
on some theory about what
actually happened to Valyria?
I don't see a volcano in here.
JONATHAN ROBERTS: There are a
couple of volcanoes in there.
I didn't have an explanation
of the exact theory,
but a number of the
questions that I asked
had very clear answers, so
there is very clearly a theory.
One interesting
thing that came up
was you see these very
straight lines up there?
These are the dragon roads.
And so these are old
roads of Old Valyria that
are die straight because
they were created by dragons.
These are the
earth-moving equipment
of the Valyrian Empire.
They could just
cut through hills.
They could cut
through mountains.
They would just go straight.
So that's all emergent.
It's like, oh, we'll make
them kind of wandery.
And I got shouted
at, so they went back
to being die straight.
So they're that straight
for a very good reason.
But you also see that
some of these roads
actually go through
big chunks of water.
And that's because that
section of Valyria has sunk.
That used to be above water.
It no longer is.
Also, there are a bunch of
cities still represented
in Valyria.
And a lot of the discussion
was, how ruined are these?
And in the final
maps, they ended up--
there's actually an individual
drawing of every single city
in there, which
reflects to some extent
the extent of
ruination of that city.
So if you get
interested in Valyria,
you should definitely check
those out and figure out
which ones are more
ruined than others.
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE]
actually sort of bothered
me the first time
when I saw that.
Everywhere else on the map,
you don't represent the roads
at all or make them very,
very shadowy, very little.
But here, they are
just like marks like
drawn with a pen on top.
It's really inconsistent
with the rest of the map.
JONATHAN ROBERTS: So
they get a little lighter
than this one in
the final version
but the dragon roads
were solid lines
because they were very important
geographic features to people
who went there to look at them.
So they were emphasized
for a reason.
Some of the other roads
got bumped up a bit.
Maybe they didn't get bumped
up quite enough in some places
because of the color
that was underneath it.
So the Red Waste
got a lot redder.
And then you can see-- so that's
the final version of the Bone
Mountains that I showed
in the animation before.
And then we get to
the far, far east.
So this is Asshai.
So this is where
Melisandre comes from.
And you have the
Shadow Lands, a couple
of other cities in there.
A whole bunch of radioactive,
fluorescent pink ghost grass.
The pink, again, was a color
that was specifically chosen.
And then the deep, dark,
almost purple forests,
jungles of Ulthos, which is
definitely terra incognita.
This is falling off
the edge of the map,
as far as the maesters
were concerned.
Other edits were less subtle.
So in this case,
we have the Paps,
which is isles off the Fingers,
which ends up on the right,
before and after.
This is my first ever
cartographic boob job.
It's like, they're named
that way for a reason.
It's like, oh, OK, right.
There we go.
I can make the Paps Islands
a double-D. That's fine.
There we go.
So yeah, it was a broad range
of comments that came back.
And so basically,
what happened was
you see all of these maps
that are lying around.
And each of those came back with
just a snow of Post-it notes,
where the editors and
George had gone through,
and they'd just added notes,
painstakingly, piece by piece
by piece by piece, going through
all the different things that
needed to be changed or
edited or moved around.
So you can see on some
of these, they actually
went on it with pen.
So you can see some of the
edits still remaining there.
But my job doing this
was just to lay them
across the floor of my
studio and start tearing off
Post-it note by Post-it
note as the edits were
made to the digital file.
And then at the
end of day, we just
had this massive waste
bin of Post-it notes.
It was like,
excellent, we're good.
Let's go on and
crack on from here.
So that was the total world map.
A lot of these dig into
much more focused maps.
So this is going to be
looking at the Beyond the Wall
map, which is sitting down here.
So this is taking
it from line art
to throw you
parchment backgrounds,
time to throw in some sea on top
of it, putting in the forests,
playing around a
lot more with that,
and then finally
completely changing
the color at the last step.
We'll do that once more so you
can have a quick skim through.
So you start off with
this parchment background
and then start throwing in
layers and layers of colors,
almost like watercolor.
You're building up very light
layers, one after the other
after the other, until you get
this kind of deep intensity
at the end of the day.
Yeah, so now,
about those cities.
The first thing, the
most important thing,
is to get the featured
locations right.
You need to make sure that
the places the people's eye is
drawn on these maps, the actual
details that people really
care about, are correct.
So King's Landing, this was
the finished colored locations
in the first map that went back.
We have the Red Keep
on the left there.
Each of the buildings there,
each of the towers there,
reflects one of the
towers in the books.
So you have the
Tower of the Hand.
You have the White
Sword Tower, which
is where the Kingsguard live.
You've got the Maiden's Sept.
You've got the core keep itself,
and you've got this holdfast.
And a bunch of others,
seven towers in total,
they're all there.
The godswood is there.
You can see there's water
down there because there
was a moat in there.
So all that kind of
stuff got reflected.
And this was what I said before.
I couldn't find a floor
plan of the Red Keep,
so it's like, oh,
let's make it up.
It'll be fine.
There's the Great
Sept of Baelor.
So that's where-- has
anybody not read the books
or seen the TV show?
Good.
That's where Ned Stark
gets his head chopped off.
[LAUGHTER]
There we go.
It's Sean Bean.
Everybody knows
he's going to die.
The dragon pits on
the bottom right,
which I couldn't find
any reference for at all.
And this was actually before the
first season, so it's like, oh.
Maybe when the first
season comes out,
then oh, we actually have
a reflection of these.
Maybe I should correct this
to be the view of that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The dragon
pit is very well
described in the recent,
what was this, description
of the war that George wrote
between Greens and Blacks.
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But it was
after you'd already drawn?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Yeah.
That came out well
after I did this.
But then I was
made aware of this,
which is an amazing illustration
by one of my favorite artist,
Ted Nasmith, who's done a bunch
of Middle Earth stuff as well,
is a proper, solid, hard-core
go-to for fancy art.
And he did this really
epic illustration
of the Red Keep, which is
totally different from mine
and really, really red.
And it also has the Great
Sept of Baelor in the back.
So the answer was like,
oh, we kind of like these,
but could you make it
a lot more like this?
OK.
And so I went back, and this is
now the same actual floor plan
layout as the keep
that he has there,
as close as I could get it.
That really, really
intense, rich red
works for his color palette.
It didn't work at
all for these maps,
so it's a much
lighter red, but still
actually red, rather
than gray stone.
The Great Sept of Baelor got
completely redesigned as well,
and the dragon pit
stayed exactly the same
because there was still no
reference that anybody could
find for the dragon
pit at that point.
Which led to an odd
thing because when
you do something on these
maps, and then the maps go out,
and then suddenly you see things
running around on the internet,
it was like, wait a minute.
So I drew that in
like 10 minutes.
It's a pretty quick
sketch for the dragon pit.
And then somebody
went and built it
in "Minecraft," brick by brick.
Huh.
Be careful what you pit
in these kind of things.
And if you haven't done
it, Google Minecraft King's
Landing.
It will blow your mind.
These guys have
just gone to town.
It's astonishing.
So a few more things
got thrown in here.
So these are a few more full
resolution details here.
The Dragon Gates, this
now has the East Barracks
got thrown in there.
We started getting a bit more
detail from King's Landing.
The original maps, if you look
in the books, of King's Landing
basically only have
three locations.
They have the dragon pit,
they have the Sept of Baelor,
and they have the Red Keep.
And now we have a
three-foot-wide poster
with three locations on it.
So a bunch more stuff
got thrown in there.
We now have the tourney
grounds are located out here
with all the bright pavilions,
where the jousting happens.
We have the Iron Gate.
Shae's manse gets featured here.
In the books, she doesn't
live up at the Red Keep.
She actually gets put
way out in the city,
so she's not under the
eye of Tyrion's father.
And lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots
and lots and lots
of little buildings.
The one comment that
came back every time
was like, more buildings.
Definitely needs more buildings.
Like up to and including some
really interesting discussions,
which we're saying,
should there be
buildings outside the
walls of King's Landing?
How many buildings should
there be out there?
I mean, this is a city which
has been very, very recently
sieged and then
recently re-sieged.
Would you, as a
government, allow
people to build
outside your walls?
Would you, as a people, want
to build outside the walls
when sieging is something
that's happening
on a fairly regular basis?
Would you, as a
government, allow
people to build right
inside the walls?
And the argument
was, well, actually,
it's much cheaper to build
three walls than four,
so if you're building
a house, you're
going to build it
against the wall anyway.
But those discussions
happened, went through,
and ended up directly
affecting how
the map ended up
getting created.
So that's the final
version of King's Landing.
You see the Red Keep
down at the bottom right.
You see the Sept of Baelor.
You can see the dragon pit.
There's also Tobho Mott's shop.
A bunch of other
stuff went into this,
to line that up with what's
going on in the books.
There's even, at the bottom,
you can see the two watchtowers
at the mouth of
Blackwater Bay, which
is where Tyrion's
chain was built.
So you can actually see
precisely when in the books
these maps would represent
because some things have turned
up and some things have not.
This is a bit more of Braavos.
In Braavos, the buildings
are much bigger,
which was a complete lifesaver.
And also, it's flat.
So we didn't have to
deal with questions
of like, how high do
the hills need to be.
One of the things that took
a bunch of time was saying,
well, actually, the hills
should be much taller
than they appear.
And when you have that
many little houses, trying
to just raise that hill--
like, this isn't a 3D model.
This is a full-on
2D illustration.
Trying to make a hill
bigger is tricky.
But we went back
and forth on that.
And the hills got
to be this size.
I think there's still a few
that could go a lot higher.
Braavos, on the other
hand, totally flat.
Much, much simpler as a
piece of work to go after.
And then you see all the canals.
And in this case, it's
just all little bridges.
There are so many
bridges in this city.
And then you get the
featured locations.
We have the Arsenal of Braavos.
We have the Chequy Port.
We have the Canal of Heroes.
And we have the
Sealord's Palace,
with an island behind it
which has a zoo on it,
which in an earlier version
of the map, the isle--
the zoo was not there.
It got added by request.
So I'm intrigued
to find out what
that means for
"Winds of Winter."
And then we have
all the temples.
So we have the temple
of the Lord of Light.
We have Isle of the Gods,
House of Black and White.
My favorite comment that
I've had so far on these
was about a week ago, when
somebody looked at this
and said, the
colors of the doors
on the House of Black and
White are the wrong way round.
The black should be on
the left, and the white
should be on the right.
You can see how small that is.
I'm very glad somebody had that
amount of care and attention
to get them the right
way round and to comment
that I'd missed that
particular detail.
And so that's the
final map of Braavos.
So that's the end of the talk.
Now we've got like eight
minutes left for questions.
You can check out the full maps.
And they're all
on the table here,
but also you can go
and pick up the book.
I'd assumed there would
be some here today.
There was a complication,
so some of you
are definitely winning
these, I believe.
There's a bunch
more stuff up here.
Website, I have
a website which I
have both these on, a bunch
of my other mapmaking work,
a load of tutorials up there.
I learned this the long way.
I'd like to help out
people by giving them
some tips and some YouTube
videos that go along with that
and then a couple of
social media things.
Google apparently decided that
my web page for this stuff
was fun and interesting.
So if anybody works at Google+
or had anything to do with that
classifier, thank you very much.
And I get 3,000 followers
a day, so cheers.
And add my Twitter feed as well.
But thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What about the
political boundaries,
the borders of all the vassals?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: So I think
that would be fascinating.
I think it's tricky
to figure out.
In Westeros, that would
probably work quite well
because you have clear
enough allegiances.
In the case of the Free Cities,
that gets quite complicated
because there are--
what's really on the maps
is the big political
centers, but there's
so much more in
those grasslands.
Like the Disputed Lands is a
land of warring baron states,
I believe.
So it doesn't get represented
in full detail here.
But yeah, a political map of
Westeros would be fascinating.
I think people have
done a few shots
at that in kind of the
style of the HBO map,
where they colored blocks
of it like a Risk map
to say who's controlling
what and where.
But that's a really
good dynamic map.
That should be like
taking one of these,
throwing it up on a nice,
slippy Google Maps layer,
putting a polygon
there on top of that.
More than happy to work
on any of the JavaScript
that needs to go
into that because I
would love to see that happen.
AUDIENCE: What
projection do these use?
Is the world spherical?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
JONATHAN ROBERTS:
Yes, it is spherical.
And there is no defined
projection for these.
One thing that the really
careful observer will notice
is that there are compass
roses and lines on these ones.
They disappear from
the finals [INAUDIBLE].
These are not-- there's
no mathematical projection
for these maps.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the show's showing
Braavos I think next week.
Do you know if those people who
work on [INAUDIBLE] of the show
reference your maps,
or if they're just
doing their own thing?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: I do know
that the books and the TV show
are quite distinct properties.
So for example, when I asked
the question, the two Red Keeps.
There's one which is
drawn by Ted Nasmith,
and there's one that
appears in the show,
and they look
completely different.
Which should I go with?
And I was quite clearly told,
go with the Ted Nasmith one.
That's what it looks like.
So yeah, I would expect it's
going to be quite different.
I know that the
Titan is different
because it turns out he
doesn't have a spear.
But that was something which
I had failed to find anywhere
in the books, and we checked
and didn't find anything.
So I think he has a sword
in the HBO show, though.
It'll be different,
but I'm going
to be looking quite carefully.
It's like, oh.
How close did they go?
AUDIENCE: So tricky question.
Greywater Watch is
a castle that moves.
Do you have any idea of
the range [INAUDIBLE]
that it exists in,
or a spatial plane?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Yeah,
I don't know that one.
That one I left
well out of this.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
come across-- you
know how the age of
heroes, they had that lamp
where supposedly the
First Men crossed.
Did you have to take that into
account when mapping it out,
what the maesters
of the Citadel would
have thought it would have
been, or what the remnants of it
would have been?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: So
that one didn't come in,
but I'm pretty sure-- well,
my guess would be it's
related to the Stepstones,
which comes across
at the very bottom
edge of there.
AUDIENCE: When you were
going through the books
and breaking down in relation
to each city and location
in relation to one another,
did you find any contradictions
that just-- the way in
which they mapped out
in the narrative
wouldn't work when
you were translating to the map?
And how did you
sort of negotiate
any of that to try and
actually have it work?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: There was
one tricky piece in Braavos,
where there was something that
just wouldn't quite work out.
I think I shouldn't go into
any more detail-- well, yeah.
There was a very detailed
conversation there
basically about it.
AUDIENCE: --itself, or maybe you
have two different characters
going to the same location, and
the way in which they describe
navigating it, it actually
makes it two different places.
JONATHAN ROBERTS:
So in Braavos, there
were-- there's lot of
different descriptions
and lots of different places.
But it turns out that
it was all loose enough
that it was possible to find
a consistent way of placing
everything.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JONATHAN ROBERTS: And all of
that got very, very carefully
cleared because, obviously,
that makes a difference,
and there was a bunch of Braavos
stuff I had not seen yet.
AUDIENCE: So you do have
to take a little bit
of creative liberty.
JONATHAN ROBERTS:
For Braavos, yeah.
Everything else was actually
really precisely mapped out.
Braavos was the one
case where there
were a lot of locations that
were mentioned that actually
hadn't turned up
in the sketch yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is Martin
now going to have
to write the books to be
consistent with your maps?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: No.
Absolutely not.
And part of that
is because-- this
is part of the reason for
the projection question
and part of the reason
for a lot of these things
is that this, these
are all supposed
to be not even factual in
a fantasy world, factual.
These are all loose
representations.
If you look at historical
maps from people
who had the same
kind of technology,
they were wildly different
between one map or another.
This is definitely
supposed to reflect
that kind of map of the world.
When you go to the
far east, you've
got things like City
of the Bloodless Men.
Who the hell knows what that is?
But that is the
whole sense of these.
There's a bunch of this which
is just very, very unknown
and, yeah.
These aren't supposed
to be fundamentally
accurate in the long term.
And particularly, when
you look at the far east,
there's a big difference
between how the far east
was represented in these maps
and how they're represented
by any of the maps
that come out of HBO.
It's a completely
different land structure.
The seas are in different
places, all that kind of stuff.
Totally consistent with how we
look at our own medieval maps.
The differences of that scale
were common and ever-present.
AUDIENCE: How do you decide
on the shape of coastlines?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: The
shapes of the coastlines
were actually really
carefully laid out already.
I mean, they were
smooth pencil lines,
so they were just broken up
and made a bit more jagged.
But there are descriptions
down to the individual cliffs
as to what they are, what they
look like, how jagged they are.
I got notes back
saying, oh, this
should be much more like small
islets and islands coming off
here.
This should be much more jagged.
This is a coastline
you can't land in.
This is smoother.
This has a beach.
That beach should be this color.
We're talking like super
granular responses.
So I did the closest I
could get with those notes
I had, and then we went
through iterations, going back
and forth on those kind
of levels of detail.
Down to the point where
in the final maps,
there's five different
distinct color and styles
for farmland across
the world map.
It's going to be hard to spot
if you don't know it's there,
but there are specifically five
different layers of farmland.
So in this world
here, I think, it's
classified A, B, C,
D, and E. And so those
were all specifically
different types of farmland,
to get an idea of the different
arable land around the world.
When you get that
level of feedback,
your job gets really easy.
AUDIENCE: So what part of
this-- I'm just wondering,
is there a particular part
where it took a very long time,
collaborating between you and
the editors and George R. R.
Martin to actually
agree on how to do it,
as opposed to being put
together, and how it worked?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Not really.
I think from my perspective,
it's impossible to tell,
like the round trip
time for that message
was due to at any point.
The editors were all
working very hard.
They passed things
on to George when
it needed to be something
that he decided on.
And then he went through
this in great detail
a couple of times
through the process
to get very granular feedback.
Yeah.
Any big project with any
large group of people,
you get some mental lag
in there for all sorts
of different reasons.
Definitely not unexpected.
AUDIENCE: So the Green Fork of
the Trident flows from the neck
to between a whole lot of hills,
down into the Bay of Crabs.
Is that downhill?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Yes, it is.
And so--
AUDIENCE: It just doesn't look--
it never looks downhill to me.
It goes between these
enormous mountain ranges
but doesn't have
any mountains on it.
JONATHAN ROBERTS: If
the north is uphill
and the south is-- [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So it's
Coriolis effect, right?
JONATHAN ROBERTS: Nah.
Yes.
In that case, there are
some hills on that side,
but yeah, it is
higher up at the top.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
all we have time for.
We're going to lose the
room in a few minutes.
So--
[APPLAUSE]